Drive by day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
You know he's a podcast.
Who?
Nick and Nate Diaz.
They should just get blasted.
They should.
They should do a,
let's get blasted with nick and Nate Diaz and just found fucking bomb on a
table.
I would the size of a nuclear missile and just fire it up and just start talking
shit about everything and have people on how people get blasted with them.
Get incoherent,
forget what they're talking about.
Just blasted radio blasted radio slash two oh nine with nick and Nate Diaz
lasted to,
how the fuck could they not have an episode?
Two Oh nine in Stockton.
They have UFC 209 is coming up and it's not in Stockton.
I Dunno.
That shit is unconscionable.
They had one opportunity ever in the history of the UFC and they should do,
they should have planned it like I planned episode nine 11 to be Alex Jones.
They should've planned episode two oh nine to be in fucking Stockton with Nick
and Nate Diaz.
I guarantee you that shit would have gotten 2 million paper view bys for sure.
Well they said if it just bomb UFC two oh nine and then just that where else and
then city of stuff they fight,
they fight whoever you know you could get them fights.
Look GSPs back GSPs back GSP versus Nick Diaz is the perfect fight to make this
the perfect fight to make cause neither guys fought in a long time,
neither guys in title contention and it's a super fight.
This a super fight right out of the gate.
Very true.
Good point.
So Tucker watching him warm up man,
his striking looks really crisp,
giving me interesting to see and really well yeah,
interesting to see him versus Sam.
But you can tell Sam's just trying to line up a shot.
So Sam throw some hay makers.
Exactly.
Dude throws hey.
But he's at least keeping his hands up for the most part.
They're starting to drop again like Cilia,
he's like famous for putting his hands right about a waistband level and just
launching bricks your way.
He actually has a fist underneath that beard.
I really think that that is the fight.
I really think that Nick Diaz versus GSP is the fight because it's a super
fight.
Both guys haven't fought in forever.
Both guys are not ranked and it's a fight you could sell.
Yes.
Like right out of the gate,
there's no repercussions.
But there's all show a lot of money we made,
and I'm hearing rumors about Eddie Alvarez fight Nate Diaz,
but,
uh,
it was,
the reality of the rumors is I'm only hearing them online.
So I mean,
they might be total bullshit.
Like I could probably ask,
you'd have to read online.
Yeah.
I have a direct line to the UFC,
but meanwhile I'm reading Instagram posts.
Oh,
for real.
Is this real?
Oh Shit.
I didn't know it was for real,
but I love that fight to Eddie Alvarez versus Nate Diaz.
That's a good fucking fight.
There's a lot of good fights that could be made right now.